I'd like to suggest that Lenny Matz is
something like maybe I should have not
put an equal sign I should have said I
am approximately equal so well any maths
is something like actually I think it's
a lot like traveling the world traveling
the world how if you are um I've
actually it done any substantial amount
of traveling anyone here like with their
families in that kind of thing
yeah how far have you traveled yep right
okay you've done a few closest that's
pretty cool um most of most of you who
didn't raise your hands I probably like
me and maybe you've gone like back where
the rest of your family lives that's
pretty much it like I haven't even
myself haven't been fun oh my ten years
now okay so either not much of a
traveler
but for those who do right each travel
the world and I think even if you
haven't travelled you can it picture the
world in terms of distinct places like
cities right there's there's I did I did
New York and then I did London and then
I did Hong Kong and so on right and
they're kind of in most people's brains
they're quite distinct things right but
here's the thing here's a thing just
like the world right in maths you think
of distinct things you think of topics
you're like we're doing this topic and
then we finished that one we've spent
three weeks on it and we moved on to
another one and it's a completely
separate thing your brain thinks it's a
totally different way and so on but
that's something that's not the way Matz
is just like that's not the way the
world is in the world all these
different places and cities they're all
connected
sometimes my obvious ways like roads and
sometimes by it not so obvious ways like
say Hong Kong and London deeply
connected why cuz it was a colony right
and you're like well you know for all of
the differences that you could leave it
this way the DNA of the two cities is
the same right
now in maths it's exactly like that
it matters exactly like that you've got
topics cities in maths if you want that
look like they have nothing to do with
each other but they're actually very
very deeply connected for example
yesterday we ended with this
do you remember I said this is not just
binomial theorem the topic I said he's
an equation and I said this is the
binomial theorem this is it this is what
the whole topic is named after right and
I did a bit of monkeying around Pascal's
triangle right and we came up with does
anyone remember it was a fraction of
some kind
what is NCR you got an N factorial on
the top which is why we spent yesterday
looking at factorials what was the
denominator R factorial x + a - a fact
good now let's just pause and remember
what this result was because all we did
was we established it kind of in a weird
sort of round that way and and then we
left it at that right what is this
talking about what is the definition of
this thing what is this we we like
second first second lesson in this topic
we gave it a definition we said this is
what this notation talks about what was
it talking about I'm starting at
coefficients write coefficients of what
yeah we're looking at a binomial
expansion well we're right in particular
we were looking at this guy and we said
well when you expand them out you have a
whole bunch of terms how many terms n
plus 1 terms right if it's squared
you'll get three time terms if it's cute
you get four to Amazon out of those n
plus 1 terms if you just look at the
coefficients we're just going to name
them we're just going to call it that
okay the our coefficient will be NCR
okay so you've got coefficients of this
algebra stuff and then we somehow
connected it to factors that we got out
of Pascal's triangle right now I gave
you a demonstration I would not call
what I showed you yesterday a proof but
it still landed us on the right solution
okay
no it's too important first you need to
know and one of them is by mathematical
induction now I'm not going to show you
that proof you can go and read it it's
in your textbook okay um but what I want
to mention first is it sort of makes
sense that you would do this by
mathematical induction can you tell me
why why would it makes why would
mathematical induction be a good thing
to appeal to one of the first things you
think of if you want to prove this think
about it what do you know about
mathematical induction what kinds of
problems does it address give me an
example of problem you could prove by
mathematical induction
what come on you can think of any to
prove it to visibility thing right so
for example just a trivial thing okay
prove that you know to and write all of
these are even numbers right now
obviously it's true but you could do it
by mathematical induction now why is
mathematical induction a sensible way to
go about this ha what is the principle
of mathematical induction you're
actually missing something off the end
of here if we were proving this one
mastered mathematical induction they
would say four and then they give you
domain what kind of domain would they
give you yeah yeah all positive integers
1 2 3 so on mathematical induction works
with these kinds of problems right and I
don't know if you remember these names
are important where they where they're
all separate it out we call these the
discrete numbers not to be confused with
discrete numbers but as in discrete
they're separate from each other
okay the opposite is continuous
factorials factorials are at home with
the discrete numbers we saw before it's
kind of confusing when you think about
halves or fracking those kinds of things
right so mathematical induction makes
sense turns out the proof by
mathematical induction it's pretty long
and awkward and difficult it's very
demanding I mean a lot of proofs by
mathematical induction ah okay so
instead I am going to show you a
different
of this result no one should have
following one with me I think it's [ __ ]
Wicca it's far more elegant but it
involves something like this it involves
me appealing to something that you
wouldn't wanna think that you would
appeal to if you wanted to prove
something like this okay so make your
subheading for me
proof of